l'armée de l'air bertrand nivard l'a
connu pendant 16 ans 3000 heures de vol
dont plusieurs comme leader de la
patrouille de france
une expérience qu'il met en parallèle
avec le rôle d'un chef d'entreprise
celui qui donne un peu la la cadence la
musique il de faire preuve d'innovation
et créatif et puis à susciter l'adhésion
c'est une place assez difficile
aujourd'hui pilote de ligne sur a320
après un passage dans la sécurité civile
il était invité par le medef yvelines a
partagé son expérience valeurs humaines
confiance en les autres membres de
l'équipe pilotes et mécaniciens réparent
alegre a fait avec le monde de
l'entreprise et le chef d'entreprise et
les îles évident le chef d'entreprise il
est là pour fédérer lors il est là pour
fédérer son équipe
il est aussi pour fédérer ses clients il
a proféré un ton de monde
un tas de monde autour de lui qui est
susceptible en fait de de réussir sa
mission est aussi le chef d'entreprise
accessoirement il a un peu sujettes au
stress donc il y avait aussi besoin
d'avoir d'autres expériences
une conférence pour parler aussi de
l'esprit de performance une notion qui
importe à la section yvelinoise du medef